[Applause]
foreign
how conventional it is in this sort of
speech at this sort of conference to
spend my time reflecting on all the good
things a labor government has achieved
in Wales and indeed I could use up all
the time I have today to do just that
because we've achieved so much together
in just the last 12 months
we've helped more than 11 000 young
people to find jobs in the very first
year of our Young Person's guarantee
scheme we've passed a new law to ban
single-use Plastics we've extended the
most generous Child Care offer anywhere
in the UK
we're providing a basic income in the
largest experiment anywhere in the world
for our young care leavers
and we've served we've served a
remarkable three million more free
School meals since September free School
meals
free School meals on that Journey for
every pupil in every Primary School in
every part of Wales
now none of this would have been
achieved without the dedication and
commitment of my labor colleagues in the
Welsh government and the labor group
whose discipline year in and year out
allows us to deliver that labor program
but while I could go on listing those
achievements I actually wanted to use
the shorter time I have with you today
to stand back for a moment to stand back
from the lists of policies and pledges
from our program of government and its
hundreds of commitments and indeed from
the many debates that we will have here
over this weekend
I want instead to say something about
the wider purpose of a labor party in
Wales
about the beliefs and values that lie at
the heart of this great party
when I was a very young child
staying as I so often did on my
grandparents Farm
someone
who we would undoubtedly have called in
those days a
came to the back door of the farmhouse
he was hungry
he was thirsty
and my grandmother busied herself to
make sure that he had food and drink
and as a child
I was a bit afraid of what I'd seen
this strange person
coming to the door
and when he'd gone
I asked my grandmother
why she had reacted with a kindness that
she had so obviously shown
and I've remembered her answer ever
since
because what she said to me was
it was because he was a stranger
and in that answer I later realized was
the seed of what led me to be a
socialist
and it's also what lies at the heart of
the enduring bargain between the labor
party and the people of Wales it's that
basic belief
that in our brief lives we owe a duty of
care
not just to ourselves
and not even just to our family and our
friends
but also to strangers
to those people who we will never know
and we will never meet
but whose welfare we understand is
intimately bound up with our own
and that simple belief
passed to me through those practical
actions I witnessed as a child runs deep
here in Wales
it's there in the selfless Act of blood
donation which so many of us do every
year
it's there in the groundbreaking and
life-saving organ donation law we passed
almost 10 years ago now and since then
copied in so many other places
and it's there in our ambition to be a
nation of sanctuary
to provide that warm welcome to families
forced out of their homes in Hong Kong
by a repressive regime or forced to flee
Ukraine because of War
or indeed all of those who seek
sanctuary from wherever
and however they may come to our Shores
conference
conference this is not simply an act of
generosity
it's rooted in our sense of a common
Humanity
in our labor history that has so long
taught us that an injury to one is an
injury to all
and it's rooted
isn't it in the sort of whales we in
this conference Hall and in this
movement the sort of Wales we wanted to
see a country which is confident outward
looking inclusive and kind
a country where our own culture is
vibrant and alive but strengthened also
by embracing other cultures from around
the world a country where we know that
Collective solutions to common problems
always make the biggest difference a
Wales where we know
that we can rely on one another when we
need help
that we can indeed rely on the kindness
of strangers
foreign
[Applause]
next year
it will be 50 years since I first voted
labor in a general election
incredibly that's almost half of Labor's
winning Century here in Wales
and the older I get
the more radical I become
and you know
part of that
is because in 35 years of that half
century when people in Wales have voted
for a labor government in Westminster
We've Ended up with the opposite with
the Tories in charge in London and
trying to be in charge here in Wales
and over that time those same Tories
have created profound damage to the case
for the United Kingdom putting the UK at
greater risk over the past four years
than at any time in my political
lifetime risk caused by the actions of
those Tory governments
now this morning I want once again
to remake the compelling case which I
believe is there to be made for the
United Kingdom
and to spell out the Urgent duty of that
next Labor government to turn that case
for the United Kingdom into reality
because the case for the United Kingdom
conference is a labor case
and it's a socialist case as well
it's the case as you heard Kia say this
morning it is the case of solidarity
of looking out for strangers
and for me today that case has four main
strands
the first
a solidarity Union
in which our actions together
guarantees that nobody has to find
themselves unable to eat and relying on
a food bank
a solidarity Union where the impact of
old age or illness or caring for your
family does not force you to the margins
of what others are able to take for
granted being a member of the United
Kingdom a labor United Kingdom would
mean a guarantee of security for us all
and the second strand in this case in a
solidarity Union
is to use the power of a labor
government to secure again those
hard-won rights which working people
have fought for for so long employment
rights consumer rights human rights
environmental rights
because to be a member of a labor United
Kingdom is to offer us all a guarantee
that those rights don't belong to other
people but that they belong to every one
of us
and a third strand in the solidarity
Union
is a strand that tells us that the
lifelong services on which we all rely
belong not to profit maximizing private
companies but to the people who make
those profits for them in the first
place the people who work in those
companies the people who rely on the
services that they provide
there is a union where the investment
available for infrastructure or public
services is not bounded by your postcode
or by borders as the nationalists would
have us believe
but where we know
that the case is a case for pooling or
resources and sharing out those rewards
a conference from each according to
their ability
to each according to their needs
so to be
so to be a member of this Union
a labor United Kingdom is to guarantee
that the public interest our interest
drives the delivery of the things on
which we all rely
but after 13 years of further Tory
government
that Union is in Peril as never before
13 years of a party that has thrived on
dividing our country hurting the most
vulnerable striking at the institutions
and the values that have bummed us
together or openness or generosity a
power to be a force for good in the
world
and so as always it falls to us to the
labor movement and to the next Labor
government to make the case for Britain
if labor is to save the union we know we
can't do that by defending the status
quo by nervously hoarding power at the
center as this Tory government has done
time and again
rather it is by building a new
partnership of equals based on mutual
respect a partnership that has the
confidence to redistribute power and
opportunity radically to every Community
every nation in every part of our
country
and we've heard today
commitments given by KIA that the next
Labor government will do just that
and we're hugely fortunate aren't we to
have that recipe set out for us it's
there in Gordon Brown's report on the
future of the UK
that powerful case for a new and
strengthened Union dearness in adding
now with
a union with a commitment to pursue
self-government and shared government
making the best of both where Devolution
is an opportunity to empower people and
to do things differently not a problem
to be marginalized or to be managed
now conference is the fourth and final
pressing issue which an incoming labor
government will have to tackle to create
this solidarity Union
and that is the thread to bear nature of
our democracy which does so much to fuel
the discontent on which nationalism and
separatism thrives
our democracy has been hollowed out by
the Tories and their Dreadful brand of
selfish
self-enriching politics where even a
football commentator is expected to tow
the Tory line or to find their job at
risks
and so
and so it is for the next Labor
government to be as bold and determined
to put the United Kingdom back on its
Democratic feat as the Tories have been
to to kick that ground from under us
and that's why the next Labor government
must lead the task of democratic renewal
it was a very important moment at our
conference in Liverpool in September
when we voted to endorse a change in the
voting system for Westminster elections
conference I do not believe that we can
go on simply accepting a system which
time and time again produces
conservative majorities on a minority of
the votes cast
and to those who continue to fear a
change in the electoral system I say
simply look at what we have done here in
Wales 25 years of winning and working
within a proportional electoral system
now I hear I hear what the critics say
but first pass the post produces strong
government
well I've lived and seen it first time
for most of my adult life the results
but strong Tory governments bring three
elections in which Mrs Thatcher lost
every single time in Wales and never won
in Scotland or in Northern Ireland
either
but she used her strong government to
destroy our manufacturing industry to
close our mining industry to break up
our welfare state and to block the
futures of young people and communities
across Wales and her successors have
simply carried on where she left off
in 2019 without winning a majority of
seats in Wales in Scotland or in
Northern Ireland we got Boris Johnson
remember Boris Johnson
a man so adrift from any sense of moral
compass that he could appear on
television to insist that everyone else
followed the rules while he presided
over a Downing Street culture that would
have embarrassed the emperor Nero
remember Liz truss
only there for a few weeks but long
enough to give us her mini budget
which very nearly crashed our whole
economy which saddled this country with
debt and which is still causing anguish
for families in every part of Wales
facing today those higher mortgage bills
conference contrast that chaos
that serial dishonesty with a leadership
that labor now offers
the leadership that KIA will provide as
this country's next prime minister
in Kia we have somebody as you will have
heard today who will put decency back at
the heart of our public life
someone who is motivated by Duty by
public service and that burning sense
which I entirely share that this party's
mission is not a tinker at the edges not
to offer some mild amelioration but to
eradicate poverty to tackle inequality
and to do that to do that with the
urgency
the urgency that those people who rely
on this party
the urgency that they look for that they
require and they quite certainly deserve
now conference it was only a few years
since I was at the cop 26 climate change
conference in Glasgow
there on the wall
throughout the conference Halls was
plastered a line from that great poem
The Wasteland by T.S Eliot
hurry up time hurry up please it's time
a message to the delegates to underline
the immense urgency of what we were
there to do
and the Wasteland that would result if
we didn't take that action to take that
absolutely decisive action to protect
our fragile planet and to combat climate
change
but they are also Words which every day
animate the government that I lead here
in Wales a government that recognizes
both the trust that the Welsh people
placed in us as their government but
also the urgency with which they expect
us to respond
that Welsh people put their trust in us
as a government because they knew we
were ambitious to get to work hurry up
please they told us
it's time to do the things that only a
labor government can do
because we know
that the purpose of a long struggle that
led to this party's Foundation was to
win powers of the interests of working
people could at last be realized through
their government
and so we exist we exist to make that
urgent change for the better
hurry up please it's time to make that
difference and that's what we are doing
here in Wales getting on with the hard
work of delivering the promises we made
to people two years ago
now our party has a long and
distinguished record of radical reform
from Jim Griffis and the foundation of
the welfare state
from an iron Bevan and the NHS to be
Advent of devolution in 1999.
and in Wales we go on
forming our track record of leading the
way introducing a new curriculum for
Wales reforming local government Banning
the physical punishment of children and
nationalizing the railways here in Wales
but I believe
conference I believe
but almost radical days can and must lie
ahead of us there are so many things
that we are determined to achieve over
the remaining years of the senior term
strengthening the building blocks of our
democracy making the council tax fairer
aligning our education system with the
needs of today's Wales ensuring that
those who don't have a first home aren't
forced out of their communities by those
in search of a second
can't have that
my Camry and Willard groys salgard they
will always be a welcome here in Wales
on North Coast is
foreign
government here in Wales is also seizing
the greatest challenge of our age the
climate crisis
one of the things about living
in this astonishingly beautiful country
is that we can all see it and feel it
when the landscape and the climate are
changing
the floods and the extreme temperatures
that we have witnessed in just the last
few years
and of course that is only a fraction of
what some people in other parts of the
world are facing where entire countries
could disappear all together
we have a profound obligation to do
everything we can to avert that
catastrophe
hurry up please it's time more of the
same will not do last year we used over
half the electricity we used in Wales
came from from renewable sources and
with a pledge you heard from here today
that will be even more ambitious in the
rest of this decade
I'm here in Wales we've already set out
our plans we will create a publicly
owned Energy company here in Wales
and that's because
the prophets that are made from the
great renewable resources of our land
are only there to be made because of the
investment which the people of Wales
make in creating the conditions in which
that industry can Thrive and it is
simply right
that those prophets are returned to the
people from which they came
and we've started
[Applause]
plant that national forest for Wales
that huge carbon sink that will help us
to protect the whole of Wales from the
impact of climate change a symbol of our
determination today to protect the
interests of future Generations tomorrow
conference the labor government in Wales
is dedicated to solving our problems
through social partnership
and I'm hugely proud that our Landmark
social partnership bill will become law
next week on the floor of our Senate
that bill
puts the long-term alliance between the
labor government and the labor movement
on an even stronger and statutory
footing
it is this social partnership approach
that has guided our attempts to find a
resolution to the public sector pay
difficulties which we've experienced not
just here in Wales but here in Wales as
well
none of this is easy conference
but a labor government here in Wales I
pledge today will always stand alongside
our friends and colleagues in the Trade
union movement when their experience of
austerity followed by Galloping
inflation drives their members to
express that dissatisfaction in the only
way they feel they can by taking strike
action and unlicatories
here in Wales your labor government will
always be there in the room talking with
our Trade union colleagues finding a way
to a solution for those challenges that
we know in Wales in that social
partnership way we can only face
together
circumference I've set out some of the
progressive reforms that we are pursuing
here in Wales but as others have already
told you just think of how much more we
could do if a labor government here
could work with a labor government right
across the United Kingdom a government
as Kia said earlier but will inspire
hope
the hope that government can be a force
for good that things don't have to go on
getting worse more cruel and more coarse
with every year that passes hope for the
Young
some of whom have only ever known Tory
governments at Westminster
and hope to for families for those who
are facing the biggest cost of living
crisis in a generation struggling each
month with a cost of a Tory's economic
vandalism
now conference it will require a huge
effort by every single one of us in this
room to evict the Tories from office
we know how hard they will cling to
privilege and to power because they
think it's simply their right to do so
but let us tell them
from this conference Hall
that we can and we will evict them
because here in Wales we've done it
before and we're going to do it again
what a fantastic night it was in May of
last year when we took back control of
councils all over Wales no more Tory run
councils in any part of Wales labor
councils from Denver show in the north
to monmouthshire in the south
and we're going to do
we'll be setting out from this
conference to achieve exactly the same
thing at the next general election a
Tory free Wales with no more Tories from
Wales at Westminster
[Applause]
now conference I began what I had to say
today by recalling my own childhood all
those years ago
and at almost exactly the same time
in 1962
Harold Wilson told our national
conference
that the labor party is a moral Crusade
or it is nothing
now we live in more cynical times
but I say to you
that our party's moral purpose is
entirely undimmed
we fight for every labor vote because
that is how we gain the right to
translate that moral purpose into action
the power to reject inequality the power
to lift our children out of poverty the
power to be that Beacon of Hope in all
perplexed and polluted world
the power to reach out our hands in
kindness to strangers
and even at the times of greatest Danger
and even when our hearts are weighed
down
with the Intolerable burden of grief
we know our duty
our moral obligation
we know
we know our duty
that moral obligation that this party
has
to run towards the dangers the dangers
that blocked so many lives and never
ever to run away from them never to
leave to tomorrow the difference that we
can make today so hurry up
hurry up please it's time time now to
renew again this party's bond with the
people of Wales time now to put our
shoulders again to the wheel of our
great moral purpose and time to elect
that next Labor government for which
people in Wales have already waited for
far too long
thank you all very much indeed